hey everybody its Jesse and the good
morning if you're in the time zone close
to mine it's 10:00 a.m. here and I have
to do an interview later on during my
normal time so hopefully this time is
okay for for most of you and maybe some
of you who don't normally get to watch
live will get to watch it live now so I
think it'll probably work out alright
I'm going to wait just a minute my
analytics are probably just a little bit
slow right now but it's showing no
viewers which I know it can't be right
because I have at least six people
waiting all right so I guess let me
check the the live chat okay so we do
have some people in the live chat so
there we go the analytics finally caught
up okay Wow okay everybody in the live
chat says it's 43 it's showing me 21
right now in the analytics and it was
showing zero and so just a few seconds
ago so hey everyone hey all right we got
some first-timers welcome welcome
Sebastian I just saw the that pool
request right before I started so I'll
check that out later on
all right so today we're gonna keep
going with our file our file uploader
and yesterday we were trying to do some
we're trying to put some security
measures in place so we had a whitelist
for files file types and we wanted to
set a max file size so let me show you
what I've done so far and this is now on
github but it's under the the branch
I always forget the name of the branch
file type check is the name of the
branch so it's not merged into master
yet but you can see I've replaced we had
kind of some really long ugly stuff
going on here in our if statement
yesterday two checks I've replaced that
with a regular expression that goes
through a lot of different file types I
think this is all we'll want maybe now
just looking at it I could see like
maybe we want that too
okay so basically all this does is it's
it's just checking all of these and it's
case insensitive so if the file type
matches any one of these then it's a-ok
to download this isn't the only check I
want to do but we have this in place now
and definitely better than it was
yesterday so yesterday we left off and I
was considering so we figured out a way
to get the total size of the form so
everything coming in from the form input
fields files
the whole thing what we wanted to be
able to do was set a file size limit per
file but I think so I've thought about
it this morning
and I think it's going to be okay server
side to have a total limit so I think
we're not gonna have to switch I was
thinking about switching to two Moltar
instead of formidable to handle the form
data because it's it's easier with
Moltar to do the checks for file size
but this is what I'm thinking have it
clear on the client side what size we
can accept so even we could even set a
file size limit client side even if
technically it still could go through if
it was a little bit bigger
we could still set one and then we could
check it client side knowing that people
could get around that but that
ultimately when it comes server side
even if if they get through the client
side stuff and try to send a huge file
or a ton of files it's still gonna it's
not gonna go through so that'll offer us
protection from a lot of small files or
a huge file either away just with the
one check so let me know if that makes
sense
that sounds alright
I wish see I think I did get rid of all
the code that we'd used before
and I wish I hadn't because it would
have been helpful since now I've decided
that I want to use it and I yeah we
never committed that or anything so I'm
not gonna be able to get that back but
it shouldn't be too hard I guess I could
have just watched my video from
yesterday I always I I it sounds weird
but I always forget that I think I
frequently think like oh man I wish I
remembered what I did you know last week
or something like that and then it hits
me like oh wait like I can just watch
the video and see what I did
oh yeah Samuel thank you for pointing
that out yeah I am I didn't mean that
the P is optional okay
I'll double-check that Sam hold on a
second let me double check and make sure
cuz I'm not really great with regex so I
want to double check to make sure that
I've put that in correctly
let's see on my other screen I had to
look it up and the first link was not
very helpful
Jax
all right thanks Samuel I'm uh I'm gonna
check this out so basically if anybody's
not sure what's going on here I just
want to know in this context I put this
question mark in here the goal is that I
want to be able to allow if the
extension is jpg or jpg so that was my
intention but I'm not sure that I did it
correctly
Samuel says I can replace this this
stock with just dark X because there's
no other actually isn't the old the old
file type is just doc right
haha yeah you're right yeah so bah bah
bah Kumaran says can't you just
basically just write both out yes I
definitely could okay so it seems like
the question mark should work so I'll
leave that in there for now
maybe I'll double-check later on I'm not
worried about it I can always just try
to upload both versions and see if it
works
let's uh let's get started and I want to
put in place first that max size check
and we're gonna I guess what we'll do is
we'll stop so yesterday we ended up
putting it inside do we put it inside
here
I have to look actually now that I think
about it I believe that the code was
pasted into the live chat so let me go
back to yesterday's live chat and just
grab that code
there we go
that was it was on progress
I said this when I grabbed let's see
all right so let me
cease
let me double-check I know we did this
yesterday and I pretty much just want to
recreate the point we were at yesterday
and then actually finish it today okay
and let me bring over this over I'll
make it a lot bigger that's really small
okay
what did I do have crash waiting for
file to use oh okay
as this
well that's why
wait oh sorry everybody it's so trouble
the syntax okay alright so what I'm
looking for basically is just to make
sure that this is giving us some values
when we try to upload something so I
have of the form open on another screen
so I just clicked upload and there we go
so the first number is bytes or C the
second number is expected
so you see the expected stays the same
and then finally it they're equal so
we've gotten everything okay good so
that's what I want so the first check
we're gonna do is the bytes expected if
bytes expected is too big right off the
bat we know that we can't accept it
and
then after that we'll keep checking just
to be sure I've never seen so far it
exceed the bytes expected but I'm just
kind of assuming that there's maybe some
way to fake the bytes expected somehow
and try to get past it so I'll do both
checks just in case
okay so what we'll need to do
all right we need to figure out how
you're supposed to stop a form from
being submitted in formidable so I
assume that there's
I really just do
all right let me check I want to check
the light check quickly I see some
things in here that might be helpful
okay I'm glad I checked this so Samuel
is saying in regard to dock the dock axe
thing that the way I have it set up
currently this would match doc or docx
but also anything else that starts with
duck his example is docked or so yeah I
definitely don't want to match other
words like that so although I guess it
doesn't really matter
yeah now that I think about it yeah
you're you are right about that I'm glad
you brought it up because I haven't even
thought about it but since I'm checking
this against the file type if I was
checking it against the file name I
would be a lot more worried about that
but I'm checking against the file type
so the type is not I mean it's not
likely to be be anything other than
regular file types so anyway if someone
has some more insight into that let me
know but I'm pretty sure it should be
okay like that but you all you are right
and I'm so if you're going to do some
checking like particularly if you were
going to use something like this but you
were going to check against the file
name then you probably don't want to do
this you'd want to maybe write out you
know everything and not not use the
asterisk of probably for anything
okay let's go back to our own progress
all right so here's what I'm trying to
do at some point it within this progress
updates the the progress update I want
to be able to just end the upload so I'm
not sure
so maybe it's farther up
yeah
all right so I'm not seeing any way to
do this
so maybe I'll have to go
let's check if we can do this in Express
yes
all right I had just figured that there
would be some easy way to do this enough
not finding it
all right I'm wondering so we can
obviously if there's an error it ends
I'm wondering how we could throw an
error let's see what we're doing already
and let's see I I forgot to start my
timer but I am checking the time so in a
few minutes I'm gonna go back to the
live chat and catch up on what's going
on there all right so let's see
okay
okay let's
I don't really know if this will work
but I think is worth the try so let's
say
i'ts expected is greater than let's just
try it which I something really low this
time just to see if we can make it work
alright so what I'm trying to do then is
just send back a bad status request
immediately on what I want to see is if
this actually will end the upload
alright save that make sure you don't
get any errors cool no errors all right
so I want to upload something that we
don't have already ok cool we got an
error but
my mine is a
okay let's get rid of that
let's try that again
okay
get a new air this time
all right so good and bad news on that
so one thing that I noticed is that this
did fire before the file got uploaded
now obviously we set it so low it's
gonna it's gonna go off
you know pretty early on but uh hold on
a second I got a knock at the door
all right I'm back sorry about that that
was my boss so in case you don't case
you're not familiar with the show this
is me doing my everyday work so
interruptions and mistakes are
definitely included and so what happens
from time to time not often but since
this is my not my normal time more
likely to get interruptions otherwise
everybody around here pretty much knows
what my normal stream time is and they
leave me alone but uh all right so let's
get back to this so I was just trying
out some things just to see if we could
you know get away with this and have it
work the goal here is to end the forum
handling as soon as as soon as we
realize that there's too much data
and we we've got this error now
actually was I trying I was trying to
upload a file types it's not very file
type anyway so I wanted to try it with
something that was it was a correct file
type so I'll switch it up and try it
with a correct file outside next time
but for now but see if we can figure out
another way we could do this
I guess if we if we did check for at
least four bites expected here and made
that a part of of what we check for we
could stop downloading anything if the
bytes expected is too large
well that would be that would be the
first step we'll give it a shot it won't
solve all the problems but so in here
this is where we're actually uploading
the files so then we know that this
already works in regard to file types so
let's try this let's see what I think I
can just get that with without having to
be in the progress see 4 bytes fights
expected ok
less than three all right so with this
what I hope that this does is if the
file type is correct then it'll go on
and check to check on the total number
of bytes expected and it anything pretty
much should get rejected at this point
since we're checking for 3 bytes so I'm
gonna try to upload a pain that's
definitely more than 3 bytes and it
should get rejected so it's alright
this is
that is a
okay so it did not get uploaded even
though I know this says that we just
never corrected that but okay I see why
it's saying that I never I didn't change
this so anyway so this did work as
expected we just have the wrong wording
in the console look but we can double
check this by setting this I don't know
like what's I don't know how big this
file is let's uh let's check it out
[Music]
250 guys
all right so let's just set this to how
they normally do it like whoops not plus
hundred times that's how you usually see
it done like and that's a lot easier to
reason about then than having like a big
long numbers
actually let's see
there's actually a cool converter built
right into Google search so if you have
if you want to check kilobytes and
megabytes and all that it is pretty
useful
huh
hm
sorry I was I was just messing around
with the converter there's actually a
lot I'm just gonna bring this over
because I think it's cool just for a
second
so I didn't realize that they actually
measure up it's probably hard to see cuz
it's small
I wonder if I can ever make it bigger so
you up to up up heavy bite anyway it's
really matter but that's crazy
all right
so basically if we set this at that
like sorry I'm trying to find that file
size again all right 250 kilobytes
that's what I thought so let's just go
300 lets you work yeah there's gonna be
some extra data well I'm not really
putting that much else in the form so
but this should work
I see let me know
I've stopped getting anything in the
live chat so I haven't gotten anything
in there for about 20 minutes which is
weird
so I don't try typing something into the
live chat so I can see if I don't see
anything in a few minutes then I'll know
something is something is wrong with the
live chat okay awesome it works great
haha everybody's just quiet
alright cool thank you for the prompt
response okay so let's try this again
and submit there we go okay so just
submitted and you see it was uploaded
just uploaded successfully
alright so cool so this works for bites
expected so I guess what's a reasonable
amount of bites expected should we set
it should we limit it to like 10
megabytes
I'm better saying for ya I'm thinking so
remember this will be total so people
are sometimes gonna upload multiple
files let me think of what normally is
so the mostly what gets uploaded are
PDFs Word documents and images so I'm
not worried about file size on anything
really except for the images so I could
see maybe an image getting big
I'll set it I'm gonna set it to 10 and
that should be that should be good I
think
it's actually
let's do it like that
wait a second
that is not what I meant to do all right
suit
times yeah so I for a second my brain
didn't work and I forgot that I had to
do that in megabytes okay so that should
give us about 10 megabytes which that
should be fine I mean we can ten
megabytes is not a lot so we can
definitely handle that and if anybody I
wonder if I should split this out the
I'm not really
did we get a success
I think we may have gotten a success
message
all right actually you know what I'm I'm
thinking too much into this right now
we're not worried about sending messages
back to the user from here this is
protection for people who are trying to
circumvent our client side stuff so
client side stuff will catch it and will
give the right feedback to the user I
don't really care and in fact it's
probably better if someone is
maliciously trying to do something that
we don't even send an error message back
to them yeah that that's better okay so
because what this is doing is it's not
sending an error it's just not uploading
that file so everything else is going on
you know as it normally would so here's
another concern so this is just dealing
with the file uploads potentially I
don't I don't know that this is possible
this would be kind of weird potentially
could someone put so much text in a text
input field that it would be it would go
over the data limit because they
wouldn't we could check for it here but
it wouldn't matter because there's not
going to be files
all right and I have had said that I was
going to stop and check the live chat
and that was a long time ago and I've
forgotten so let me stop and check the
live chat now it's not a bad place
because we got step one of this finished
and working so let me scroll up and a
live chat I'll take any questions you
have now for about about five minutes
I'll set the timer
I might go a little over five since I
skipped I skipped ahead and did more
coding
all right cool so we have Vinicio since
a little from Brazil awesome welcome
Sean says it's first time from Phoenix
Arizona hey Sean welcome really glad you
could join us for the first time feel
free to ask any questions or putting
comments in the live chat
oh cool err drifter says I'm done with
HTML and CSS tutorials awesome
congratulations assuming now you'll
you'll start getting into JavaScript
stuff so if you have any problems and
want any help let us know in the live
chat or message me or something I'd be
happy to get some advice if if you need
it and if I get a chance to
Slick Rick asks what are you coding he
asked us a while ago so he or she asked
us a while ago I am not sure if you're
still still around watching and you've
probably got it already but um it's a
file upload we're handling file uploads
in node we're using formidable as our
package or another package to help us
handle those we have the file uploads
working but now we want to try to rule
out which uploads we want to actually
which files we actually want to upload
and which ones we want to reject based
on what type of file they are and how
big the files are
okay
all right so krill ik has a question
I guess so is it fine to render or not a
component depending on the state of
another component in react for example I
have a navigation component with filter
component inside and I render filter
only if navigation he's a state state is
home is true okay so only if navigation
state is I was true yeah
yeah I think that's fine so basically so
you have you have navigation as your
parent component then filter is being
rendered inside navigation you have a
state of his home when it's set to true
you want to render filter so yeah
definitely I would just put it put it in
a ternary so let's um let's bring up I
guess let me bring up a javascript file
so we'll get the syntax highlighting
here but let me go down here so within
your render or you know you return
you'll probably want to do something
like this so this state is is home and
then you can since you're just checking
if it's true or false you can actually
just short circuit with an and then
after that you can put your what was it
called filter
so you could do something like this
right so this would check it would check
the state if the state is true it's
gonna filter if it's not true it's not
going to do anything so let me know if
that's helpful or if that fits your use
case or if I'm misunderstanding what's
going on there
but if anyone else has any input into
this you know please please weigh in
here but as I understand the question
this should work so we're doing this a
lot between this project and the last
project we've we've used pretty much
this exact set up somewhat frequently
okay so we did have my timer went up but
there's only a few more questions so I'm
just going to do them to get to the
bottom of the chat here so techie Tintin
says what does the jape JPEG with a
question mark in the middle mean
so let me I'm gonna get rid of this
hopefully it was the hopefully kerlick
had a chance to check that out I just
don't want to leave that in there and
accidentally I wouldn't really be able
to accidentally save that cuz I would
get an error but rather just take it out
now so this part here is is what you're
asking about
what it what I'm intending this to do
and I haven't tested it yet is to take
either jpg or jpe G so basically the
question mark here means the e would be
optional
but originally so recently I did have it
like this and then Samuel said that he
thought it should be like that so I
started to look it up but then I figured
like I'm not gonna spend the livestream
trying to look this up I'll just look it
up later so definitely before you try to
use this test it or look it up because
I'm not a hundred percent sure what it
is I'm just I don't really use regex
often enough to memorize what all these
things mean so I just look it up every
time so I need to verify that this is
correct
okay so when I had said I asked earlier
about would it be possible for somebody
to put so much text in a text input that
it would exceed our max limit for size
and Umberto's has potentially yes unless
you're only getting the first you know X
characters from the text box of this so
there's some character limit yeah that
sounds like a good idea and I could do
that
I'm thinking can I do that client-side I
mean obviously I can set limits
client-side but I'm thinking for
somebody who's gonna try to get around
that could I send could I only send a
certain amount off to check it out I
don't think I'm gonna do any client side
stuff today I'll say that I'll probably
work on it myself later on I was just
going to do some server-side stuff but
that's that's a good point thanks
somebody to techie Tintin says you rock
bro first time here awesome
I'm glad glad you think that and so
hopefully hopefully you stick around and
I are able to watch some some shows in
the future and I contribute in the live
chat or ask questions okay
Mei has Mei Mei HFR I'm sorry I'm
probably mispronouncing that but I'm
trying trying Mei hitch flora says hey
hey hi Jesse what time do you come live
usually usually it's 2 p.m. Eastern Time
but occasionally I have to switch that
up depending on what I'm going on
haha nobody says a few weeks ago I
didn't know JSON at all it's cool I can
watch this stream and understand what
node1 is doing that's awesome
he also says hey Jesse this might be a
sidetrack but would love to know your
thoughts on node.js if you have any
experience yes so I'm a big fan of
server-side JavaScript because it allows
well it allows someone like me to do
full tactful stack type of stuff without
having to learn another language which
is cool there's nothing wrong with
knowing more than one language and
that's awesome if you do but there's
only so many hours in the day and so
much time you can dedicate to learning
so if I can dedicate all my time to
JavaScript then I'll get better at that
then if I was learning more than one
language
so the general concept of it I'm really
a fan of I don't have I wouldn't say I
have a ton of experience actually doing
server-side JavaScript with node I do
stuff like this like we've been doing
you know just some I don't know I guess
this is basic stuff file upload things
some routing so I I hope to do more with
it and yes so that's my I guess I don't
know if that's what you what you wanted
in terms of an opinion but I just think
it's it's really really cool to be able
to use client-side and server-side
JavaScript and then it allows you to do
other stuff like people are doing
Internet of Things with JavaScript it's
like everything that you can do with
other languages it seems like people
have figured out how to make it happen
with JavaScript and I don't know that's
really cool it's not like I think
JavaScript the greatest language in the
world I don't think I've been
supposed to enough languages to really
make a decision like that but it's what
I know the best so the fact that you can
use it so many places means that I could
potentially code those different things
and that seems really cool and fun for
me let's see
all right so I've got through all the
questions let's go back let me set my
timer this time so we'll definitely do
yeah we'll probably do one more Pomodoro
session and then the to finish up I'll
answer any questions you all have if you
haven't seen this this stream before the
end is saved for question-and-answer
from the live chat so stick around for
that if you do have questions or if
you'd like to stick around and help
answer that would be awesome as well
this stream benefits greatly from the
expertise of everyone who's watching and
contributing if it was just based on my
expertise it would not be nearly as
helpful to you all okay so yeah so this
is working now we want to yeah the
second step was to check the bytes
received and then stop hmm stop it based
on bytes received this is going to be a
little bit more tricky
so here's why if I try to look at bytes
received here in file begin it's gonna
say zero or at least for the first time
that that runs it's going to say zero so
there's going to be stuff already
getting uploaded which I guess is fine
yeah that's probably fine because what I
want to do is just cut it off at some
point okay so let's try it out let's
just console.log it first to see what we
get and let's get rid of this
okay and I'm gonna have to upload
multiple files to really see this in
action now the what this isn't really
going to protect against I suppose is
one really big file so I guess I'll
still have to find some way and there
may not be a way with formidable to do
that
I mean progress those go with chunks all
right let's just try this first and then
we can worry about the other stuff okay
so let's see what we have okay yeah
definitely so we did get we actually did
get a value for the first time which is
cool when we tried it before I think I
think we tried it yesterday we did get
zero at first so
that might actually be useful let's try
it with one file and see what we get
okay so here's my bytes received okay
this might actually work then if we if
we are actually getting some something
here this will be somewhat more useful
than I thought it would be so let's just
I guess put in
okay so
one if I can try let me try so I'm gonna
try to upload a really big file so I
think I do have some videos recorded at
pretty high quality that will definitely
be more than what do we have ten
megabytes so let's try that
okay let's see here we go here's a 40
megabyte one
all right here we go yours there's a 500
big one alright so I'm gonna try to
upload this 500 megabyte file and let's
see what happens
Wow well I've never seen the loading
modal before because everything's
uploaded so fast but I finally saw it
and it looks great
so that's good so I I did it on my other
screen but let's see all right let's see
what value we got oh no it got rejected
because of the file types and QuickTime
oh I'm gonna have to rethink how I'm
checking these file size
okay cool so this this wasn't the result
I was looking for but I'm glad it
happened because this uncovered a bug
that this could have been really bad so
what it looks like though is at least
for this file is that would have gotten
through I mean assuming that I could
have faked the bytes received thing
there the the bytes expected thing this
would have gotten through because that
that first time that fired you can see
it's it's only registering 16,000 bytes
so yeah so that's not going to protect
us from huge files trying to get
uploaded but the problem is excuse me
it's yawning the problem is I pulled
this from one of my previous projects
and in that project I was actually
checking the file name and not the file
type so these aren't gonna work for
everything so I you can see that I'm
allowing the MOV extension but that's
not what came up as the type the type
and was QuickTime so I'm gonna have to
get another list I'm not gonna search
for a list right now during the stream
but I'm gonna try to search for a list
of common file types and I'm gonna I'm
gonna replace what I have now with that
list
okay
I'm gonna keep this in here because it
still could have some use but I don't
know I guess we'll have to find I'll
have to think of some other way
so for right now we are protected from
lots of smaller files being uploaded so
that's good I mean that's better that's
better than nothing at this point that's
a step forward I still would like at the
very least I would like some sort of
protection from very long file input
values and from someone trying to upload
one very large file and the the final
thing is assuming that the bytes
expected could be faked to make it
appear less than it really is
which I'm not sure if that's possible or
not if I find out that that's not
possible then we're fine but I don't
know you never know people come up with
all kinds of ways to get around things
all right so I'm gonna commit this and
then push that to get up and see how
much time we have left
Oh straight here okay all right so we
checked in what we changed good only the
server J s has changed which is what we
expect we're committing with the am flag
which means we're adding and putting a
message in at the same time we're
committing let me say
okay that works yeah
okay so a lot of our tests are running
now if you have a project without tests
on it that will have a pre-commit hook
that run on a pre-commit hook then
you're not going to see this and it's
going to be a lot faster but if you do
download this repo you're gonna see
something like this so now you won't be
freaked out when you see it I guess and
remember if you do want to check out
what we've been doing you have to switch
to the file type check branch and if
this code is not on the master branch
okay so twelve minutes left in this
moment or a cycle I'm not sure that it's
worth it to try something else
the odds of me actually getting
something else to work in ten minutes
are small especially since I'm not
really sure what I want to do next so
this might be a good time to take
questions
yeah so I'm gonna go to the live chat
now I'm gonna scroll up to where I left
off at there's not a whole lot in the
live chat so it shouldn't take me too
long so if you do have any questions
please get them in there quickly so that
I can answer them otherwise if you don't
if you can't stick around for the
question answer session and you're just
here for the code thank you so much for
watching please watch again sometime if
you can and let's let's go to the lodge
where did I stop
alright so I'm scrolling up to the live
chat that has the timestamp of around
11:00 a.m. okay cool so no D had asked
the question about nodejs
and in response he says make sense been
trying to learn it the past few weeks
cool
yeah I I think it's definitely worth
while there's so much you can do with
node nowadays so if you're if you're not
sure what what to learn and you're
looking for something to try out
I think Note is a good route to go right
now
okay so Bastian says that I shouldn't be
looking at bytes received through the
air if the bytes expected or bigger than
what you want okay and I'm there too
saying but I'm also checking to make
sure bytes received is less than by it's
expected to separate checks yeah that's
that's what I was trying to do Sebastian
says I may be wrong but if you stop and
upload based on what it's already
uploaded you might end up with filled
halfway uploaded aka useless files yes
so what I guess I'm not so much worried
about useless files so potentially so
there's going to be client-side checks
in place so people who are genuinely
trying to use this for what's an intent
it's intended to be used for are going
to be stops client-side from uploading
anything that they shouldn't be
uploading in terms of type or size what
I'm worried about on the server side are
people that have circumvented our
client-side protections so I don't
really want their files anyway so if I
only get a half a file and it's useless
I'm fine with that
I would I would prefer getting nothing
but if I if I need to stop it in the
middle that's fine with me
as well
okay umberto says
that he would send a message back to the
client indicating the upload failed and
the case that receives is greater than
expected yet anyway um I'm not I'm not
sure if you sent that message before
after I explain my reasoning why so I'll
just reiterate it again for anybody that
wasn't around when I did explain that so
normally I would want to send back a
message but in this case as I said the
user if if that occurs it's likely that
the user is trying to do something
malicious I don't really care about
sending them back anything telling them
that it failed I would almost I would
rather have them think it succeeded and
then have them know that it failed and
try something DIF
African flight star says this is really
cool for a newbie coder like me to
actually watch live how the experts do
it very helpful
thanks for saying putting me in the
category of expert I appreciate that I
don't know that I would put myself in
that category but I'm at least expert
enough so that people pay me to do this
anyway
hopefully you do get something good out
of this and if if you're new to coding
and you have any questions definitely
let me know in the live chat or you can
message me on Twitter or some other
social media platform Dave says sorry if
I if asked only just been sent tuned
into what program alright so profuse
assists
okay so the question from Davis is
basically what programs do you use dave
is just starting to learn again on free
code camp if you're just starting on
free code camp you won't really need any
separate programs at first once you
start to get into some of the projects
some of the later projects you'll need
it so I use the adam text editor that's
8000m it's free our side code editor and
for my terminal I use I term - I think
that's Mac only for Windows I think I
use Commander it's a Cmdr I'm pretty
sure that's what I use I haven't used it
in quite a while though so I can't
remember for sure I think that's that's
it for you know any special programs I
mean other than what I have you know so
I have no js' installed on my computer
and NPM and then I install my packages
through that so but that's probably if
you're just starting in with free code
camp that's a little bit more than
need to worry about right now I would do
your free code camp things and when you
get to that point where you really start
you need to develop things locally on
your own computer you know then you know
get into some of you know learn get
learn how to use NPM kind of easier way
into it sometimes it is helpful to be
able to start with somebody else's
project and kind of see how they have it
set up as long as it's not too complex
but anyway you will get a lot of you'll
see a lot of how that works on these
streams it's not really a tutorial but
at least you get to see it in action and
I'll do my best to explain it and feel
free to ask any questions along the way
if I'm going too fast or something
you're not sure how something-something
works okay cool African flight starts
says just signed up with free code camp
and I'm looking forward to diving in
that's awesome that's really great seems
like the last few streams I've had a lot
of people say that they're just starting
with free code camp and that's great
it's good to hear that a lot of people
are getting into that I think it's a
great resource thing I mentioned before
but my wife actually just started I
think she's only on her second week of
doing free code camp but that's kind of
cool now I can talk about coding stuff
with my wife and she understands me
so anyway Dave said thank thank you for
the info but you're welcome hopefully
it's it's helpful to you all right so
I've gotten to the end of the live chat
and I think we're actually we're
actually going to be finished in under
an hour and a half which that may seem
like a long time to you but compared to
some of the other streams we've done
this is one of the shorter ones so I
will be back tomorrow I will just lose
today Wednesday tomorrow's Thursday
yes it's Morris Thursday I should be
good to go at the same normal time yeah
so probably expect the stream to
2:30 p.m. normal time Friday extreme
will probably be a little bit earlier
than normal as well but I'll let you
know more about that tomorrow and on
Friday morning but until then thank you
for watching thank you for helping out
in the live chat all your contributions
I really appreciate it and have have a
great day